bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
rendez vous dans vie de lecture avec moi
notre invité laurent garin bonjour jean
voiture vous êtes venu nous parler de
deux romans aujourd'hui tout à fait de
revente ils se parlent
oui qui peuvent se lire en miroir alors
sur la thématique principalement de la
colonisation
donc ces deux romans qui sont sortis la
sur la rentrée littéraire de 2018 donc
le premier c'est david diop nike frère
d'âme qui a reçu tout dernièrement le
prix de goncourt des lycéens aux
éditions du seuil tout à fait donc un
premier roman qui nous emmène sur la
grande guerre sur la vie des tranchées
dont qui nous raconte l'âpreté des
combats mais principalement une histoire
d'amitié
donc c'est entre alpha et mademba qui
viennent du même village sénégalais donc
des tirailleurs sénégalais qui sont
enrôlés dans l'armée française
donc un des deux un des deux personnages
va mourir enfin on va essayer enfin va
être très grièvement blessé et son
compagnon d'armes ne va pas réussir à
l'achever et ses contres sac va se
battre c'est justement ce deuxième
personnage pour sauvegarder la mémoire
de son compagnon de compagnons d'armes
et donc c'est tout ce récit là de
l'amitié qui va perdurer dans les
tranchées donc ça on a vraiment un récit
qui est très dur sur la vie des poilus
des poilus des tirailleurs sénégalais
qui étaient de la chair à canon et on a
eu tout aussi cette histoire de cette
amitié qui va durer et qui va essayer
jetons en mémoire de son ami qui a perdu
qui a perdu sa vie lors des combats qui
va donc essayer de faire se poursuivre
durant tout le reste des combats donc
c'est un parallèle entre le 7 mai et
cette amitié sénégalaise cette terre du
sénégal et les tranchées françaises
oui c'est ça et tout cette histoire de
deux personnes qui comprenait pas bien
pourquoi elle a été là ce qu'elle
faisait précisément et donc toutes ces
personnes qui finalement était en relève
pratiquement de force sur ses combats et
qui étaient devenus des vrais chair à
canon puis c'est toute une histoire
c'est toute l'histoire de la france et
c'est toute cette histoire aussi de
l'amitié entre ces deux hommes là qui va
durer et donc vraiment vraiment
puissante sur l'amitié vraiment sûr sur
cette thématique aussi donc il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de violences donc
il ya un déchaînement de violence suite
au décès d'un des deux protagonistes
et c'est ce déchaînement de violence qui
qui apparemment est en opposition avec
la boucherie de la wii c'est la cas du
site de la rédemption de ceux de ce
soldat l'a en fait de la rédemption
vis-à-vis de son ami qu'il a vu mourir
sous ses yeux et qui va essayer donc de
de trouver
un peu de paix à travers la continuité
des combats dont il va devenir
extrêmement violent sur sur les
adversaires
et donc c'est oui c'est un récit très
choqué ses frères d'armes
oui c'est ça ouais au point oui oui en
plus il y aller avec des coupe-coupe
enfin c'est une arme qui était autorisée
par l'armée française
donc les tirailleurs sénégalais avait
des couples non qu'ils aient achevé lors
leurs adversaires beaucoup oui donc fait
toute cette voie là cette réalité du
terrain de la guerre qui a raconté dans
ce récit qui tombent enfin
juste après les commémorations donc
voilà en pleine actualité on est en
plein dans l'actualité là et c'est une
autre vision de la guerre de tranchées
vraiment sur les tirades tirailleurs
sénégalais et vous avez il ya un
deuxième roman que vous appartient
aujourd'hui wiki et estelle sarah bull
pour là où les chiens aboient par la
queue qui indique t-on créole donc là
c'est un autre pan de la conel
colonisation française
donc c'est tout la seconde moitié du 20e
siècle qui a raconté de la guadeloupe
donc estelle zahra bulle en fait
s'appuyer sur le récit de son père et de
deux de ses tantes pour produire ce
récit en fait d'une histoire familiale
une histoire de fratrie entre ces deux
mondes entre la guadeloupe et la
métropole
donc c'est tout
toute l'épopée familiale justement entre
ces deux terres là entre ces deux mondes
là entre ces deux communautés qui conte
qui se confronte aussi et qui finalement
doivent vivre ensemble la guadeloupe
c'était aussi des des bretons qui sont
partis en guadeloupe c'est ça
des colons à camphin en banlieue
parisienne où oui ça critique à créteil
tout à fait donc l'auteur enfin que le
personnage principal vit à créteil et
elle même elle est issue d'une mixité
franco-belge et guadeloupéens je crois
que c'est ça le maire était agrandir la
frontière franco belge et son père et
guadeloupéens donc elle même était déjà
dans une une mixité
elle a baigné dedans c'est enfin le
roman est articulé aussi sur un
métissage des mots donc il ya un vote
créole un peu de français 1 me un
métissage des moeurs en métissage des
comportements et voilà c'est vraiment il
ya plein de personnages français assez
foisonnant sur ça il ya plein de
personnages très vive très intéressant
fin très piquant et on vit donc cette
épopée sur 50 ans de cette fratrie qui
vit justement son retour en métropole on
parle d'un roman polyphonique qui
magnifie et qui est un hymne à la mixité
c'est ça au métissage rometty sa
polyphonie puisqu'il ya tout un
foisonnement de personnages et français
très châtié
oui et bien écrit c'est sérieux donc et
ironique
elle a donc eu le prix stanislas 2018 et
le prix carbet des caraïbes aussi tout
dernièrement
donc voilà et donc c'est une auteure
qu'on va recevoir nous a livré on est
très heureux de ça on va la recevoir le
8 décembre à 15h30 donc ce sera tout le
moment de lui de l'interroger sur sur la
création de son oeuvre et de son premier
roman très bien et puis c'est moi qui
vais vous présenter un livre une bande
dessinée aujourd'hui c'est le dernier
lucky luke un cobaye à paris ii hd et
juin jules au scénario fou et hd au
dessin hd ça fait ça fait 9 9
numéro 2 je crois qu'il a repris 7 ans
qui l'est c'est ça qu'il est sûr qu'il
est sur lucky luke et jules c'est son
deuxième scénario c'est un peu un second
souffle pour lucky luke
hélas ce qui est intéressant dans ce
lucky luke il ya vraiment une double
lecture donc jules a fait un vrai
travail historique de recherche
tout est vrai tout est précis ça et on
apprend plein de choses sur la statue de
la liberté sur paris de l'époque est
vraiment il y assez double lecture qui
est vraiment lucky luke qu'on connaît
pour la jeunesse mais lucky luke que
nous aussi et adultes on arrive à
trouver plein de choses plein de
références plein de favori de cette
double lecture est vraiment précieux
téléspectateurs re si tu sais c'est en
fait lucky luke qui devient le garde du
corps du sculpteur bartholdi qui a qui a
créé la statue de la liberté et qui est
parti faire une levée de fonds aux états
unis avec un morceau de la statue de la
liberté
ça devient juste le bras et la flamme et
cette grande tournée lucky luke la
campagne pour le protéger bien sûr on
retrouve les grands classiques de lucky
luke va dire les daltons les indiens un
grand personnage
et puis ensuite lucky luke quitte pour
la première fois le continent américain
il avait déjà fait quelques incursions
au mexique et au canada et il débarque à
paris il débarque à paris et on apprend
plein de choses sur vraiment ce que ce
café bartholdi dans le xvième il a
vraiment monter la statue de l'est vers
les ateliers zattry dorsale de
stationnement parce que les ateliers
trappe les ateliers gadjé et bartholdi
vendée ou pour promouvoir cette statue
des petites miniatures qu'on a appelé
des gadgets qui a donné le mot gadgets
et quand je reconnais qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
et dans cette dans cette bande dessinée
il va rencontrer bien sûr des
personnages français célèbres comme
monnaie rimbaud il va être séduit par
emma bovary
il rencontre si victor hugo et bien sûr
il ya quelques hommages aux 6 2
de jules à cabu au fondateur de charlie
hebdo qui ne peut pas trace sans bien
sûr de l'histoire de paris de la bande
dessinée il ya donc il ya quelques
dommages au 7 janvier au 15 novembre qui
sont chers à jules bien sûr et au monde
de la banque beaucoup sur victor hugo
s'il ya beaucoup d'hommages sur victor
hugo et pour les passionnés des frères
dalton donc là ils sont quand même pas
trop présent sur 7 sur cet album mai
prochain ils seront de retour très
disait jules parfait voilà donc un
vraiment une bande dessinée à a
recommandé un cow boy à paris aux
éditions lucky comics je ne peux pas
quitter cette émission sans vous parler
d'un événement tv 78
le festival saint quentin qui arrive à
la fin du mois du 28 novembre 2 décembre
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le site
50-1 point fr beaucoup d'événements
autour de ce festival c'est au final
pour les cinéphiles avec une grosse
sélection de films documentaires sur le
thème de l'espace est aussi une
programmation au ciné cette et à l'ugc
de sur des films de science fiction vous
aurez plaisir de revoir lors des soirées
et également quelques signatures en
quelques quelques signatures avec ledit
casse en soit déviée bel ami pascal picq
pour l'inauguration pour la soirée
d'ouverture qui a assuré le maire que
l'histoire ça tout à fait et ensuite il
y aura les frères bogdanoff voilà et
reçoit réu gc avec les frères bogdanov
qui seront en dédicace qui seront
interviewés par jean claude bourret tout
à fait donc la librairie partenaire de
de l'animation sera présente pour les
dédicaces en faire saigner les affaires
singes également il ya une soirée de
clôture qui se déroule si le dimanche
soir au ciné cette vous pouvez retrouver
toutes les informations sur le site
internet
il ya bien sûr une sélection de films
documentaires et l'ugc et le ciné sept
ont aussi accompagné avec une sélection
de films de science fiction
il ya aussi beaucoup d'événements autour
du festival c'est à dire des conférences
docteur marotte des conférences avec
airbus sur les femmes dans l'espace
il ya aussi des ateliers pour les
enfants il ya aussi un planétarium
gonflable et je vous invite à vous
rendre dès à présent sur le site
télécharger le programme et je vous
remercie d'avoir incité assister à cette
émission laurent et je suis retrouvé
très bientôt et oui bientôt un prochain
au moins estivales se croisera combien
de joueurs avec plaisir et à très
bientôt très bientôt
[Musique]